[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALI AFSHAR: Hi everyone,
welcome to
Google Developers Live.
My name's Ali, and today I'm
going to be talking to you
about the Google Drive SDK, and
specifically a new feature
we launched last week called
the App Data Folder.
So how are we going
to look at this?
Well, I've written a small chunk
of code, and we're just
going to walk through it so
you can see the basic
operations, how easy it is.
First, I'd like to talk about
why should you care.
Why should you as an Android
developer care about storing
your data in the Google
Drive App Data Folder?
Well, this is a bit about
the App Data Folder.
It is a folder that lives on
your Google Drive that is
specific for your application.
So you can store
data in there.
The user can't actually read
or modify that data.
What they can do is they
delete that data.
And it's in their drive, it
takes up their storage quota.
So there are no limits on the
data size apart from the
amount of quota that the
user has available.
Obviously, if you're using up
all the user's drive, then
they're more likely
to delete it.
So it's a folder specific
for your application.
No one else can modify
the files.
No one else can read
Only the user can delete
them if they're
taking up too much quota.
OK, why should you use
this from Android?
Well, why should it matter?
Well, I personally think people
are getting to the
stage where they've
got multiple
devices on multiple platforms.
Now, one of the beauties about
Drive and the Drive API is
that you can access it and use
it from any platform, really.
And part of that is mobile,
but say if you have an
application that also has a
desktop component, or a web
component, or someone might
have a tablet, an Android
tablet, or an iOS phone.
You want to be able to have
some way of keeping data
synchronized across all
these platforms.
Now, Drive is that,
essentially.
It's the best way.
People have Google accounts.
Many people have Google accounts
and they come with 5
gigabytes of storage.
So you don't really need to
think about, does the user
have an account, do they
have enough quota.
You can just go ahead
and use it.
Now, on mobile, that's
particularly useful for any
state you want to share between
instances of the
application.
So that might be configuration
data, it might be application
state, for example, which window
is open, which tabs
they had open if it's a browsing
kind of application.
You might want to log history,
for example.
Say you have a history of
commands that a user did with
an application, or maybe
even an Undo History.
You could make that across
all different platforms.
And of course, for situations
like saving games, that's
another potentially
huge case here.
You don't want the user to be
able to modify the saved game
file, you want to be able to
store as many as you like, and
they can delete them as
and when they wish.
OK, so that's some
of the use case.
I think it's particularly
powerful on mobile platforms,
because people do have more
than one mobile device.
So that's App Data.
How can we use it?
Well, fortunately, it's
really, really easy.
Now, I've written a tiny
little application.
The first thing we're going to
do is just run through the
application.
Just run it, and then we'll
talk about how it works.
So if you can see the Android
tablet now, it's very simple.
I've got a background and I've
got a single button.
OK, so I'm going to click the
button and we get a little pop
up saying we've created
a file.
It says found, and
it says updated.
OK, so we've done three
operations, and hopefully
those are the basic operations
you need to get started.
So let's have a look at
some of the code.
I first started by taking the
Android Quickstart Guide--
sorry to jump around.
It's here, developers.googl
e.com/drive/quickstart-android.
Now, that is the best way to
get yourself up and running
with the Google Drive
API on Android.
It has a number of steps.
If you go through them
all, it will work.
Some of them are a
bit complicated.
It took me a while to
get them all set up.
It includes, for example,
plug-ins.
You need to Eclipse, the Google
plug-in for Eclipse.
But if you go through all these,
you will get up and
running as soon as
you possibly can.
So I took that application.
That is a camera application.
It takes a photo and
it uploads that
photo to Google Drive.
So what I've done is, I've
removed all the camera stuff.
I don't really want to store
photos, so I've removed the
opening of the camera.
All the other uploading of the
photo, I've removed, because I
want to store custom files
in my app data folder.
So what I did do is, I've added
the button you saw, and
on clicking of the button, it
will run this run method.
OK, now, the run method
essentially starts a new
thread, calls main, and catches
all the exceptions.
And I've done that just so I can
write code freely without
having to worry about
exceptions.
If you're in a production
environment, you may decide to
do things differently, or the
same, or however, but this is
just to make our code
look simple.
So we have this run method
that starts the thread,
executes main, and in main,
I've got our code.
So let's go to the top.
So I've explained to you what
App Data is, why should you
care, hopefully, the
prerequisites you need to
install this, they're all in the
Quickstart page, and we've
run the application.
So the first thing we need to
decide is, what are we going
to call our file.
OK, now I've just got a string
there, the title, and I'm
going to call it configuration
file.
OK, and then I've got a file.
This is a drive file resource
from the Drive API.
I'm going to call it config,
and it's going to be the
latest file we have as we're
going through this procedure.
OK.
So what's the first thing
we want to do?
We want to upload some content
to the App Data Folder.
OK, the first thing you'll need
is some actual content.
This can be anything.
We have different adapters for
uploading files, for example.
In my case, I've got a
byte array content.
And that just takes a
byte array in memory
and it uploads it.
So as I say, it could
be a file.
You could load the
file from disk.
One thing you do need to do is
always pass a MIME type.
We're using text plain here.
Now, this is the MIME type that
the file gets stored as.
You have to have it there, and
it's actually part of this.
So always remember, you have
to add the MIME type.
So we've got some content.
That's what we're
going to upload.
Now, files in Drive, there's
some metadata
associated with them.
Title, whether they're starred,
permissions, owners,
that kind of thing, in addition
to some binary content.
So this is the binary
content part.
Now, in the metadata when we
insert this file, we have to
make sure two things.
One, it has the right title,
which you'll see down below,
and two, we set the parent to
be the App Data folder.
That's absolutely key.
If we don't set the parent to
the App Data folder, then it
just won't go there.
So how do we do that?
Well, it needs a list
of parents.
A list of parent reference.
Now, a parent reference is
just really a container
which has an ID.
So I create that list, I create
a new list, and I add
the parent reference.
Now, you'll notice here
that I'm calling new
ParentReference.setId.
How can I do that?
Well, this has some kind of
builder pattern so that most
of the setter methods that
I can call on this parent
reference instance actually
return the instance itself.
So I can change these together
to make it much more
comfortable, and much more
readable, and just for me to
write less code, which
is always good.
So I add that, and then I create
a new file, so the
drive.file resource, and I set
my attributes that I want.
So as I say, again, using this
kind of builder pattern, you
set title to the title and I
set parents to the parents.
OK, this file resource is
generated from the discovery
document, so it already has all
the method's you're going
to need, and it's always up
to date, which is great.
So I do that, and finally,
I need to insert
that into Drive itself.
So this calls the API method
of files.insert.
Service is my instance of the
Drive service that's been
authorized.
And I insert it with-- the first
argument is the file
itself, the metadata, and the
second argument is the binary
content that I created
earlier.
And then I have to remember
to call execute.
This actually returns another
file, so I'm resetting it to
be the same variable.
So that's the first
part of it.
And after that, I give the idea
of the file I've just
created and I send a
message. showToast.
We can look down here.
showToast is just a
method to show a
notification to the user.
And you saw them popping up.
It just makes sure it runs from
the right place in the
right thread so I don't have to
keep writing that code out.
So if I were to run that again
up until where we were there--
I'll run that again.
OK.
Hopefully we should get a prompt
for the account user.
This is all part of
the quick start.
When you get an account user,
you can either ask the user
every time.
That's perhaps not the
best user interface.
It might be better
to store this in
configuration, however you want.
But always please, please,
please give the user the
chance to choose which account
they want to use for that,
otherwise they will go crazy.
So we do that.
It will do nothing now, apart
from waiting for me to click
the button.
And if you just see the
first pop up that
comes, there we go.
Created.
So that's actually [INAUDIBLE]
go off and do the rest
of the script.
So that's actually created a
file in our app data folder.
And let's have a look at
what that looks like.
Inside Google Drive itself,
hidden behind the gear we have
Manage Apps.
Now, Manage Apps is a dialogue
that allows you to configure
what has access to your drive.
Every application, whether it's
an Android app, whether
it's a web app, whatever has a
drive token, or you've use
authorized for a drive token
will appear here.
And your users can use this
dialogue to revoke access, or
do whatever they want
to your application.
In this case, you'll see here
that we have now hidden app
data, 1 KB.
So I've created this
app data file, and
it's now present there.
And as I said, I can't
see it as the user.
But what I can do is go into
options and I can delete the
hidden app data.
So I delete it now, and the
config file's been deleted.
So if I rerun my script,
it will recreate it.
OK, that's the first part and
probably the most important.
How do you create an
app data file?
So two components.
The mets data, the file itself,
upload them to the
correct folder, which
is app data.
Now, app data, we use it
as a string, as an ID.
It's actually an alias.
This is a real folder
with a regular ID.
So what you can do is you can
call a get on the app data
folder, and you can actually
find out what its ID is.
This will make things quicker.
Obviously we have to do
the lookup on the
back end for app data.
If you store that ID, then
we wouldn't need to
do that look up.
So it's just quicker there.
Again, if you have a place
to store it, it's
useful to store that.
Right.
So that's the first thing we've
done, created that.
The next thing I want to show
you is how do you get files
out of your app data folder?
Well, you can call get
if you know the ID.
In more situations than
that, you probably
don't know the ID.
You might want to find it.
Now, how would you
find it there?
Well, I'm going to use two
criteria to find it.
The first one is a file has to
be in the app data folder.
We can use that.
And the second one is we're
going to make sure it's called
the same thing as what
we called it up here.
Configuration file.
OK, so the method of the
API I'm going to use is
drive.files.list.
OK, first thing I do is
create a request.
I'm not executing the request
immediately, because I need to
modify the request to add
my query parameters so
I can look it up.
OK?
Now, the query parameters
I'm going to set
are this query here.
And just talk about that.
App data in parents.
This is saying, this file
must have a parent that
is called app data.
Again, you could substitute the
real ID of the app data
folder if you have
that in there.
And which joins this, the
title equals our title.
So I'm looking for a file
in app data which
has the right title.
And of course this is
a list, so it might
return more than one.
It might return a few if you've
got them, but this is
your folder.
You know what's in there.
If you have two in there, it's
because you've created two.
You should probably
know there.
But this sample doesn't
take care of that.
Once we've set the queue
parameter, we can execute our
modified request and call
get items on the result.
Now, get items, again,
this isn't
checking for errors properly.
Gets items is a list of file,
drive.file types.
So exactly the thing that we put
in in the first place, we
get a list of them back.
This might be empty if we don't
have it, if we haven't
previously created anything.
In that case, what we
do below is we check
the size of the array.
The size of the list is greater
than zero, and if it
is, we just blindly take
the first one.
Again, as I say, that could go
totally wrong if you've got
more them one, but it is
your stuff, so you
really should know.
And then we're going to put a
message found if we found it,
and not found if we
didn't find it.
It's going to be found, because
obviously we just
created it in the
section above.
So if I'm to run this again
this time, sorry, you're
getting pretty bored of
looking at this demo.
But I just want to highlight
where it's got to.
OK.
So creative.
And then it should say found,
and there we go.
it says found.
So we've listed your app data
folder and taken, using a
query of the file name that we
want, which is stored in the
title parameter.
So that's how do you find the
file you've made in your
configuration.
So we created it, and
we've fetched it
back, and using a query.
OK, great.
The third and final thing I want
to show here is how to
update the data.
So that's really useful,
configuration changes in one
place you want to update
it, so you put some new
configuration values.
This time I'm actually going
to put some JSON in there.
I've hard coded a bit of
JSON into a string.
For those of you who are wise
and watching closely, you'll
see that my MIME type is still
text plain, which is wrong.
The MIME type for JSON
should be application
forward slash JSON.
But that's OK.
For the purposes of this demo,
it doesn't matter.
It's likely that you won't
change the MIME type, you'll
just change the content.
So we create another byte array
content using this string.
Obviously you would use-- you
have a data structure.
You might have a config object
that serializes itself to
JSON, XML, whatever.
YAML.
A million different things
you could use.
And remember, this is not
just for android.
It would have to be a format
that you could parse easily on
your iOS app, or your web
app, or whatever.
So using a generic one like
JSON is pretty good here.
So we create a new one, and
again this time we call the
method files.update--
drive.files.update.
And that takes three parameters
this time.
The first one is the idea that
you want to update, which of
course is the same ID of the
file we've had-- config.getId.
Then the file metadata.
Now, this hasn't changed, so
I'm just going to pass the
thing I got back in there, and
that's going to be fine.
And again, the new content.
And then I'm going to show
the message updated.
So if we just run this
for the last time.
OK.
So we get the first message.
We've created it.
Not found.
They're not found.
OK.
So this time it failed
to find it.
Shall we give it a proper go,
so that we can make sure it
does actually work?
Let's take that off.
Found.
So if you were watching last
time, you'll know that I ended
up with a 404 not found, so I
really just couldn't do that
again this time.
That would have been too
unfair on you guys.
So what have we done?
We've created a file that you
can use on any platform,
hidden from the user, that
contains configuration data.
In any format you want.
It can be any binary
format, any
proprietary format you have.
You can use that for config,
application state, save games,
history, the list is endless.
Any data you want to be
available everywhere.
So we've created that.
We've then fetched it back from
Drive, and I've shown you
how to update it.
You'll see that's just a
tiny amount of code.
I've got 60, 70 lines including
the comments now.
Any Java program will tell
you that that's a
tiny amount of code.
So it's easy to do.
I believe you should do it.
No application I know would be
worse off by knowing about
different instances running and
being able to do something
about that for the user.
It may be nothing, but just
knowing about it and having
that option available, I think
will improve all your
applications, mobile
and otherwise, OK?
So if you have any questions
about this, please make sure
you ask on Stack Overflow, or
join us on the community.
And apart from that, thank
you very much for coming.
Thank you for watching.
Good luck with building these
Android applications, and
other platform mobile
applications.
Tell us about them.
We're always keen to hear.
Thanks very much.
Take care.
[MUSIC PLAYING]